we're begging catsuits me we're sorry
just like anything to me hey everybody
it's Charlie this is gonna be my
Westworld Season 2 episode 1 video we
already had some crazy time jumps
there's all kinds of crazy stuff to pick
over so here we go we don't even make it
one episode without a giant time jump
but remember there were three timelines
during season 1 so of course there's
probably going to be multiple timelines
during season 2 in some form but I'll
try to explain what that big vision at
the end was so just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet and
if you are new to the channel I will be
doing videos for all the episodes just
like I would normally do for a game of
Thrones so I will do a trailer video for
episode 2 tomorrow because we see all
the stuff that we did not see during
episode 1 like all the people coming
back and some new characters - including
James Dell O's Logan's father the person
that created the Dell O's company that
is now led by the man in black but let's
do a top 10 so starting with Arnold in
Dolores back thirty years ago talking
about the nature of reality I'm afraid
of what you might become this is just
teeing up Dolores is revolution arc her
going full-blown Wyatt although as
Dolores and present-day explains she's
neither the ranchers daughter or full
Wyatt anymore she's evolved past that
but it's just
Arnold giving the skynet speech I'm
afraid that this simple computer that
I'm creating is going to exterminate the
entire human race at some point via the
really important thing that you may have
seen in that intro is is that the robot
descends into the water the intro
sequence is just a little bit different
from season one that's also a hat tip to
the dream that Arnold talks about that
he has and he also says you know dreams
don't mean anything which is also alive
because during season one Ford said that
dreams are very important when he was
talking to Dolores by himself the dream
though recurs several times but also the
idea of what is real so he's mostly
referencing his dead son remember that
was really important for Arnold's
character that was then given to Bernard
when he was modeled on Arnold's
brainwaves Fez sort of a parallel form
Aves ark when Sizemore tells her that
her daughter isn't real she's just a
story we created and she's like are my
memories not real is my body not real
therefore then isn't the way that I feel
about my daughter real regardless of
what her origin is number nine a little
more world-building with the del o's
corporation more teasers for the outside
parts
so we get to meet more of the corporate
people a couple new characters there's
the Strand character who's kind of in
charge from the dello side of things he
seems more like the military person so
if you don't think that Charlotte is now
the lead
Della's person that I guess that this
strand person is supposed to be but we
also meet another important new
character Kosta who is a Della's person
and is just sort of like their version
of a Bernard like he's able to diagnose
the host he pulls the core of the memory
out so they see that Dolores is the
antagonist that was kind of what that
was for to let them know that Dolores
had gone full-blown Wyatt and she's the
person leading the revolution so even
though she's technically not the villain
she's kind of an antagonist for season
two but a lot of that just depends on
whose perspective you're taking because
a lot of the episode is actually told
from Bernards perspective you begin with
him as Arnold but you also end with him
at the side of the beach what looks like
very very far in the future they talk
about communications being down at the
other parks - so it's just teeing up the
idea that we're moving beyond this park
and that also happens a couple times
later in the episode with more direct
references like we didn't think that
things could cross the boundaries
between parks but you start to notice
how good they are with weaving this
imagery into the season so you have this
Native American character it's part of
the ghost nations storyline but when
they order Acosta to open up his cortex
so they can take his brain out they're
effectively scalping him they're
scalping the Native American you're
mostly witnessing this all from Bernards
perspective and he's kind of in shock
and horror at all this and he seems
really disoriented to begin with but
he's a host that thought he was a human
this whole time so there's this big
question about where his allegiance lies
is he going to help the hosts because he
is a host or is he going to help the
humans because he thought he was a human
this whole time that's also a really
important tip off for the man in black
storyline this season - like which side
is he going to pick is he gonna help the
host out is he gonna help the humans out
number eight though following up on that
Dolores tease she's gone full-blown
Wyatt executing guest holding them on
trial I was a prisoner of your dream and
your desires now you're my prisoner
you're inside my dream this is really
just meant to tell you who the Dolores
character is now her personality isn't
that of the ranchers daughter or of the
why
character it's something more something
unpredictable but this is really
sinister connotation especially with the
revelation at the end of the episode for
what her grand plan is but when she was
speaking to those prisoners while she
was stringing them up you may have
recognized some of the dialogue when
she's talking to this person here it's
the same exact dialogue that Ford gave
to her when they were sitting alone
together then there's the more funny
obvious reference where the guest
screamed for help as she starts to ride
away saying doesn't look like anything
to me so number seven welcome back man
in black it was a great intro scene like
he sort of crawls out from underneath
the bodies cleans himself off puts his
formal man in black costume back on and
smiles like this is crazy but he totally
loves it like this is what he wanted
last season he wanted real stakes he
wanted the host to be free he was a
person last season that was all about
playing the game that was meant for the
host the maze is not meant for you but
the child Ford host tells him that this
new game this season this is meant for
you you have to find the door he says
it's all about getting out yes that's a
metaphor and a literal thing because
they have to get out of the park and
they're trapped there now because Dell
OHS is holding up for that insurance
policy host but child Ford says the game
begins where you ended and ends where
you began I think where he began is
where he began as the man in black like
when he stopped being William and he
started being that crazy person if you
remember there was that episode where
Logan woke up around all those bodies
and he's like William what did you do in
the young version of William has gotten
like full man in black and gives him
this big long speech about the nature of
reality about how he's figured it all
out I know what this is all about now so
it almost sounds like his game this
season is about turning back into the
original William like being a good
person being more of a protagonists in
it Harris has said some stuff in real
life that corroborates a little bit of
this he says that he sees his character
as a protagonist of the season he's not
looking to solve the maze that storyline
is over is all about atonement for him
so think about it this way Dolores his
character isn't evil this season but she
seems kind of like an antagonist in the
man in black seems kind of like an
antagonist but he's not evil either so
it's sort of like the moral graying of
all these characters no one is really
good and no one is really bad but just
in general is
like the man in black is gonna be more
sympathetic to the host this season
number six mavin Sizemore this was
totally hilarious obviously mostly
comedic relief from their storyline
because Sizemore has the pissed taken
out of him almost literally because she
makes him go full monty at the end of
the episode but it just tees up the idea
that she's gonna be looking for her
daughter and it lets you know what the
different groups are going to be this
season so you have Maeve Hector and
Sizemore then you have Teddy and Delores
as group then you have Bernard and
Christina's group so sort of three
different perspectives that you'll take
during the season between Dolores Maeve
in Bernard who are kind of like the main
characters on the show even though me
and black technically a different
perspective
Edie Harris would probably tell you he's
a main character too but it'll be
interesting to see which story lion's
mane and black crosses over like will he
cross over with these other separate
three groups the cool thing about Maeve
storyline like they tease the idea of
the other parks in the Bengal tiger
crossing the park border Maeve is the
character that will cross into the other
parks so we'll see all that through her
storyline like Rinko Kikuchi is part of
their Shogun world storyline it seems
like we'll meet her next week's episode
one of the funniest moments between the
two of them though was when she
threatened to cut off his bits and feed
them to him and he says I wrote that
line for you and then she makes fun of
the lion saying that it's kind of broad
like don't you think he could have
thought of something better but number 5
the big WTF facility that Charlotte has
on the DL that Bernard didn't know about
but somehow his DNA is coded into the
system so you wonder if that's Ford that
did that or if the dello Sport thought
that he was human and just programmed
his DNA into there's a lot of questions
about who knows that he's a host and who
thinks that he's real because I think
that pretty much everybody in the dello
storyline aside from Ford who's dead now
thinks that he's real so he's walking
around all season long keeping this
secret and that's a little bit of their
scenes here when they're in the secret
base where he tries to fix himself so we
learn that the board is secretly
capturing DNA and memories from all the
hosts that visit basically everything
that happens to them while they're there
as well as their own personal DNA the
early theory what might be going on is
the Dell O's will create clones that are
robots for people to upload themselves
into like if you're rich enough to visit
the park because
is crazy expensive then you're probably
rich enough to buy yourself an
artificial body to upload your
consciousness into so like why else
would you need someone's DNA other than
to create a special clone for them that
was a host that would never die it's a
really cool thing about this though you
remember the man in black is the CEO of
the delos corporation so any shady stuff
that charlotte is doing and teases for
that storyline
the man in black probably knows about
that number four though we find out that
the Abernathy character is Charlotte's
special insurance policy the delos wants
and it's basically called off all rescue
operations and it's gonna leave them
there to rot until they find Abernathy
remember he's Dolores his father from
season one the ones that glitched out
talking about eating people and
Shakespeare at the same time it was
totally freaky and totally awesome but
now they're bringing him back through
this storyline but the easy setup is
that he's gonna be one of the MacGuffins
of the season and he has some sort of
secret information r2d2 style stored on
him the del o sneeze to continue their
plan number three Bernard starts to
glitch out he finds that he's basically
going to self-destruct in less than an
hour unless he fixes himself we saw in
the trailer that there was a room full
of Bernard copies which is probably what
was being created down in Fords secret
lab where Teresa was killed remember
there was a host that was being created
and we're like wait a minute who is that
host that they're building there that's
probably the base where Ford built all
the backups for Bernard in case he
needed to repair him or he needed to put
him in a new body because the one that
he was already in was completely
destroyed the idea though is that when
he gives himself the transfusion of that
host flute-like whatever it is that
keeps his brain working it says that
there will be temporary memory loss and
blackouts that's when you jump to what
looks like the end of the season it's
like when you're taking medicine and you
see side effects may include temporary
memory loss that's basically what's
happening to him so we're gonna get a
lot of unreliable narration through his
character where you jump around in time
because he's jumping around in time
because of these memory blackouts so
just remember if it seems like there's a
bunch of missing footage like there was
with Bernard at the end of the episodes
like hey wait a minute how did we get
here from the secret base it's because
he's experiencing memory loss but at
some point he will have to fix his body
number two though was Dolores --is full
plan
she explains what the real deal is like
we can't just take this world we have to
take theirs from them as well so like
the real terror of this is the idea that
she's going to try and conquer the world
eventually but we've seen scenes with
them in the real world even though they
kind of seem like flashbacks
so just remember multiple timelines this
season but Dolores really does sound
like she wants to conquer the world and
when they say that we found it they
might also be talking about the
Abernathy robot like her side is like
one side of this conflict they find it
but the Dell owes people need it so they
need to get it from her but the number
one WTF is where they find that secret
Lake with all the hosts inside it and
Bernard says I killed them all so you
see teddy floating under the water
meaning that this is probably in some
future timeline
so remember may experience memory loss
it becomes this big question of what
happened during the season - cause
Bernard to turn against all of his
brethren because even though he
identifies as a human he really is a
host so it makes him seem kind of like
the villain of the season if he really
does wind up killing all the hosts but
let me know in the comments what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and all your big questions obviously
there were a bunch of questions because
this episode was mostly to let you know
what the different alliances were going
to be who the different groups that will
follow around we're going to be in what
the big MacGuffin was the new game that
the man in black is playing Maeve
finding her daughter the Abernathy host
the delos is looking for in Barnard
trying to decide what his allegiances
are my episode two trailer video will
post tomorrow morning so just look out
for that but in the meantime click here
to re-watch the season 2 trailer now we
know that there's actually a bunch of
footage from what looks like the end of
the season in it and click here for
brand-new Game of Thrones thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
we'll see you guys tonight